hello reject nation I'm Greg Alba
I'm jonald Humphrey we are going to
watch today a video called envoi and and
this is from the channel called Black
Sun entertainment this video is a few
years old over our patreon we do TV show
reaction watch alongs as well as weekly
Q&A is one of our top reward tears
whatever video you request one was
definitely do and put up on the youtubes
usually a reaction got one coming later
this month that will not be a reaction
this one black Sun entertainments comes
from a man named can't make know it kind
of chatting just a little bit as of late
missing man I know you had to go through
all that surgery stuff last time we
talked you look like you were in good
spirits and even back in work lately
hope everyone's not being a dick to you
being like Soul kangaroo now so I put a
couple of shrimps on the Bobby yeah
just saying Australian cliches all day
hope that books coming along bet you've
been reading for like three months now
called twelve that's still faster than
how fast I read anyway I miss your smile
man I just miss you I miss you a lot
come over to America what are you doing
come back to us you can you got to have
reached the limits of what Australia can
offer you come back to us
come back to us that's not a noise
[Music]
I have one of those cameras on a little
boy do ya
yeah where can i watch the feet
it's in my bedroom so the kind of jokes
you get at the real rejects James Gunn
was writing for us now
oh man that [ __ ] kid did all that
[ __ ] recognize that one
white kids always cause trouble
[Music]
[Music]
seriously time so basketball so we run
that stupid ball just at the camera
listen car think you should stopping on
the field so much you should because
it's not normal okay
in grandma and grandma keep on asking
questions they're worried about you look
look how I miss mom and dad to you
but you can't keep on hiding out there
this doesn't have anything to do mom and
dad hey there's nothing wrong with me
something looking in the corn and I can
prove it if we get all the way out there
there's nothing there you're doing
dishes for a week this is how real
brothers ever talked I would know it's
funny cuz he called the basketball
stupid but like what's he gonna do with
a skateboard out here skating on the
field man is gonna go do this I score
Atlanta last it's about to do right now
okay see practice portable bench it's
gonna hop that 90s basketball commercial
what now it's okay for it it's like a
Spielberg vibe yeah how to tell you I'm
liking this sci-fi thing we're getting
yeah that dudes pretty wait for it wait
for it
some Michigan J frog [ __ ] I don't
understand that reference John oh he
only performs one like the one God's
around
he tries to show anybody else who's
regular frog whoa look at the arm on
that thing in the field at least the dog
side
oh he did see
[Music]
it's gonna rock it back and his brother
in the face 30 skateboard whoa want to
play what now throw the dog
oh they're gonna throw the dog oh so we
know how evil okay at least not towards
dogs the brighter more like a prequel to
quietly
that's that's unexpected
oh yeah
[Music]
it's the iron predator this kind of look
like spoiler alert I'm here in search of
the Allspark I'm looking for bigger
calves yeah I want to poke my knees up a
little more oh dude dude doesn't
bumblebee got its inspiration yeah this
thing likes to play basketball or
something oh it's letting air in it's
fence wow he's really good yeah
oh no oh damn this is the iron
oh damn dog yeah that is a great great
well
[Music]
vo your After Effects team is pretty rad
sandwiches
[Music]
- tired - my man
maybe shouting from you think that you
don't even know what it's capable or
what is doing here
you're gonna tell me where it is mature
patient contact I don't know who that is
John remember the grocery store clerk
and Ted sitting there the whole time
maybe you should have stood up and dark
the whole time
yo imma kill this guy on your behalf in
voi David Weinstein
Adam Coggan so did this get turned into
a feature film that's what they were
aiming for here ideas I wouldn't be
opposed to it becoming a feature film
look pretty charming I mean reminiscent
of a couple things for sure yeah
especially like the Iron Giant with that
speech well I have thoughts we can
review this short film matter of fact
we'll make our review longer than the
short film 55 minutes yeah shot-by-shot
Braden sweet that's pretty sick okay so
talking about this we have to keep in
mind this is four years old so did not
ripoff bumblebee not rip off shame
blocks the predator know if anything
they ripped off this short film yeah
because there's a lot of those vines I
made a joke about the front side of hid
looking like iron predator explore the
greatest movie of all time and then it
had the dreadlocks I was like oh [ __ ]
this really is the predator to Han
that's crazy but he hit the nail on the
head there when you said that it does
have Spielberg vibes major more than its
sense of wonder and a young kid
discovering some alien life force and
the military like there's a lot like the
Wonder in the music was right there but
then it just can't be more spill broke
bad military police them attacking first
which is already a trope in and of
itself even having though like a horror
element yes since the danger you know an
intensity yeah well even through the
perspective of the soldier like when the
alien shows up at the end of like okay
well this is from the soldiers
perspective so we're gonna capture this
like it's a terrifying creature we know
it's not we know it's kind didn't throw
the dog back in the field yeah it was
just had no interest in the dog yeah I
don't know what you are yeah you're not
a ball this isn't clear to me and the
child being full of Wonder was a nice
touch I I thought this was executed
really well a lot of time you see short
films on YouTube or just short films in
general it's so the quality of a short
film there's usually like something that
just gives it away
and it's usually sound and I got to
commend them on the sound design here
because usually where you go wrong with
sound design the dialogue scenes
especially out in the field
well we're listening to em like this is
like professional quality sound is
that's usually the number one thing that
pulls me out of these kind of short
films is terrible sound design and it's
invest individuals with visual actually
over dial honey yeah it's like they'll
have like cool I call the Machine
sounding effects we're all great but
this is a dialogue that really worked
and the cinematographer here was x12
this is great it's great looking film
this is like great and that's why I made
the crack of lights do they make this a
feature because it feels like a sizzle
reel put together for a feature this is
one of my favorite corners of YouTube is
when you find like a surprisingly
well-made short that people clearly put
a lot of TLC and skill into and you got
to imagine like this was just for the
sake of doing it for the chance yeah did
somebody might see it and pluck them out
of obscurity and I wonder if anything
has happened for these people since then
because this video has millions of views
now so when it gets got visibility I
mean if this guy's not directing right
now you know it's gotta you have
levelled up since this I'm sure there's
some script on some Hollywood Shelford
that's family
yeah I'm sure some studio has the rights
to something for this yeah now we and
now because of the lack of success of
monster trucks we might never get yeah
yeah and that monster truck that monster
trucks and the acting was good too I
mean the thing about it is this is an
extremely well executed short film on a
technical scale from music to sound
design to even the visual effects but
the close-up on the hand coming in I
don't know if that was practical or not
but looked very authentic it looked very
real and there were certain shots to
where obviously it's CGI but it looked
pretty damn good the only thing I wish
for that to be enhanced a little bit
better and it's a short film so you
can't really have too much crap about it
would be the dialogue itself like the
dialogue in terms of sound design is
great so I was able to have watch it and
easily pay attention to it it was very
cliche types of dialogue which lends
itself to a cliche like performance come
on grandpa
worried about you nerdy
in the buff older brother the cooler
guys probably trying to be tougher both
of them or something you know doesn't
bully Aaron Sargon I couldn't tell if it
was like Oh Maj or just cliche yeah it's
kind of right cuz I'm like all these
Spielberg things are there but I wasn't
entirely sure what line the lines were
falling off even like the military
dialogue was very cliche yeah everything
everything felt like cliche Nats
dialogue but that's something that could
easily improve let's say let's like
playing the hypothetical game that this
were to be something that they were
trying to pitch and making it something
that's a feature film
honestly you got all the hard stuff
really like yes dialogue is hard however
that's something you can improve on a
typewriter don't write this next one
yeah this is something you can easily
improve on final draft all the technical
stuff is the hard stuff that takes years
of experience really masters so the
dialogue is not really an issue in terms
of trying to make this something bigger
but so it's an effective piece it's an
effective short film now there's some
cliche dialogue still good acting that's
fine too yeah yeah for sure I mean I
feel like for me at least I look a
little bit past dialogue issues in
shorts like this because you don't have
that much exactly and I can't really
harp on it yeah yeah yeah for sure but I
mean that is the kind of one element
that was missing but I thought
especially doing that intro with the
interrogation room cutting you know to
the flashback it's like I was completely
pulled into the flashback to the point
that when we cut back I was like oh
that's right there's a way around to
this I would see this movie and look at
what envoy means a messenger a
representative especially one on a
duplicate patent diplomatic yes l'm
attic mission so is the kid the envoy or
is the machine the envoy or yes and one
on the skateboard he's the true message
there's not your messenger I feel like
that could be kind of both ways than I
mean I guess my first instinct would be
to say the robot but you know the kid
could be sort of the Envoy
humans yeah delivering the message of
peace and inclusion to the misunderstood
robot killings yes holy [ __ ] this guy
David Weinstein he is one of the visual
effects artists for many a Marvel films
Pirates of the Caribbean the Ben Hur
Suicide Squad edge it's um Wow no wonder
the effects look so damn good
the major matrix films holy crap man
returns I mean he's got some like
not-so-great movies everything there's
some amazing ones here too I mean
frickin to have infinity war under your
belt oh yeah I was really surprised been
able to get this film going I mean
probably know your father's you'd have
want to make some cool because I'm busy
making this yeah you see The Avengers
Wow I did holy crab good for this guy
man that's awesome
well you know those visual effects guys
for 300 made a VP Requiem yeah that was
stellar so we need to get more people
definitely transferring cinematographer
for many in nolan films made
transference and many films since then
and the editor for star films made saw 5
which was the best saw as the editor
made saw 6 the production designer did
the saw 5 fact well this is a cool short
film no wonder he doesn't regularly
upload because he's already making
millions of dollars doing real stuff
thinking when I started this channel I
have no time for alright well Kent
thanks for introducing this to us buddy
that was one hell of an interesting
short film you guys can subscribe to the
reject nation click that notification
bell cuz you know why check us out on
patreon yo hat through if anything find
your favorite creator who has a patreon
page and go support them because they
deserve it if you love them that much
take care of people